the Joe Rogan experience my favorite
video in New York is the rat that's
killing the pigeon Jefferson oh I never
saw that oh I saw Pizza rat yeah Pizza
rat ain't [ __ ] on pigeon killing rat the
[ __ ] rats killing a pigeon well
that's like the woke brigade yeah very
similar taking the pigeon down and and
attack it and the pigeon tries to flood
away and the rat [ __ ] I didn't know
rats are predatory yeah I thought they
were mostly just scavengers yeah I
didn't know they would actually go after
a live thing and attack it and kill it
yeah desperation man was it was it in
the subway area or is it on the street I
think it was on the street cuz I don't
think pigeons actually go into the
subway it's a good point to the most
part if I get [ __ ] over and they make
it out seen seen a few in an airport
before oh here it is so here's this this
pigeon and this rat is crazy bitch-ass
pigeon though like come on flap it out
they have some big [ __ ] teeth these
kunti rats you know they never got by
the neck look at that they'll never stop
growing rats teeth really yeah they have
to keep that's why they're always known
because they're partly it's filing them
down give it a go I know many more
animal facts and I actually do remember
that now that you bring that up
look at this [ __ ] thing and though
the pigeon gets away at one point
slightly right there oh yeah but look at
them chase it down over here
pigeons so damaged he can't get away
totally can't fly oh so eventually he
drags it through the hole in the fence
and [ __ ] it up that's hilarious when
you go into their lair and the pigeon
knows that he's like I can't get off the
street okay it's mounting him it's kind
of back his head it's like khabib yeah
very similar holy [ __ ] can't get away
he's smashing you I said I just didn't
know they killed things yeah I thought
they only just ate stuff that was laying
around but there's so much food in New
York City they were just run around
eating everything right they eat each
other I do know that oh really I do know
that because I had a try I lived in
Encino and I was renting this house in
the house and a lot of
and leave my garbage in the garage and
you know put it out in the morning and I
was seeing these rats so in set a trap
not mice rats [ __ ] rats big rats
so I hear snap so I go out to check and
there's a fat boy
that's got his head crushed in this trap
I mean he's dead as [ __ ] so I'm like
okay I'll just get in the morning I
don't want to deal with that right now
yeah so I get up in the morning and the
only thing that's left is the tail Oh
everything they'd everything there was
the feet in the tail though all the guts
the body the spinal cord everything
there was just like a stain and the tail
rat tails are so disgusting that even
rats any practice there's a lesson there
you hear that rednecks yeah get rid of
those rat tails here's the move you get
you poison a rat then get it in the trap
then they eat the rat then they get
poisoned that could be something yeah
you could but the problem with poisoning
rats is a lot of times it doesn't kill
them immediately and then coyotes get it
and then they get poisoned and then
mountain lions till the poison coyotes
or they kill the rats right so ours also
get killed by rat poison it's real
problem with owls because a lot of
people leave rat poison outside their
house and then the rats eat the poison
they get weakened then owl comes in and
eats them certainly life circle of life
damn did you you lived in New York yes
you had mice I'm sure oh yeah yeah I
lived in New Rochelle though I never
lived in the city I couldn't afford it's
right next to the Bronx okay yeah that
was my smash oh yeah mice are everywhere
they're brutal and they really I'm so
scared of them I know it's like a wussy
thing but when they're running around I
just jump up on the table yeah I can't
handle it's brutal
I have to call it like a masculine
friend to help me mmm even when they're
on the trap screaming I don't know what
to do I take a broom stick I stick it to
the sticky trap and then I go outside
and put in the garbage can just while
they're still alive yeah so you let them
just suffocate out there yeah yeah
that's on them you figure it out it's a
weird system right the ecosystem of rats
and mice and humans
it's a strange thing yeah there's a lot
of them and they've killed us with the
plague apparently that was all rats
what's the fleas really fleas from I
think Crimea came over on boats attached
to rats and then the rats got ran
through Europe and [ __ ] everybody up
cry me a river I love words did you ever
see the Netflix documentary called rats
no oh my god you have to I don't know
have to it's you you just go what first
of all they all have diseases oh yeah
all of them I mean you just don't come
in contact with them but if they bit you
like you're [ __ ]
most rats are [ __ ] yeah I did all
these tests on rats and different parts
of the country too and New York City is
I think they said it's either the number
of rats is the same as the number of
people that live in New York City or the
biomass I'm not sure which one but both
of them are equally terrifying yeah if
it's the biomass it's actually more
terrifying right because it means
there's so many rats that's the same
mass of bodies as you are a few millions
but I don't think they really know I
mean there's any [ __ ] surveyors down
there in the subway how do they go no
also if you measure the weight of all
human beings and all ants it's even yeah
I know that I love a fun fact that's a
weird one right yeah answer freaky to
man they said if an ant was our size it
would be faster than a Ferrari whoa give
it a go whoa yeah Kalen at one point in
time bryan callen wanted to be what is
it what's the type of person who studies
entomologist that phrases right
etymology is words entomology is study
of insects oh yeah and so he did some
time in the jungle oh and they were
they'd have to put turpentine all over
the posts of these platforms that the
tents would be on because there's so
many ants on the jungle floor that you
said he was lying in bed you could hear
the answer you could hear them walk in
sync yeah and when they get on something
there's so many of them yeah they just
kill they kill elephants come on they
climb up the elephant's body and
go right into its ear and just start
eatin its brain man what can Elvin do
take a goddamn thing you can do is
really close to a giant river and it
could jump in and try to drown those
little cuts right brutal brutal it's a
ways to go we've we've lived as human
without had we survived primitively well
we got lucky but then we got smart and
when we got smart then we started
overpopulating yes and we figured out
all these different ways that nature was
kind of keeping our bodies in check
keeping our numbers in check mm-hmm you
know like we like we have systems for
rats and mice and all these different
things to keep them in check well nature
sort of had a way to keep humans and
child predators diseases starvation
injury so you're saying we beat nature
we beat nature which is probably why
we're so [ __ ] up mentally because
we're not supposed to beat nature well
we're a little too safe for sure
for sure we're all contained in these
buildings where the no predators can get
us we all get doughy like little [ __ ]
human water balloons right and one cling
of discomfort and we we have to fix it
work on it [ __ ] yeah we complain yeah
we're getting our jaw shaved down to
look prettier Oh
digging throughout to New York they
don't know how many there are their
system ended of 250,000 the tens of
millions but this is a new trap that was
put Bricklin this is a video of them I
guess testing it it's an alcohol trap
where they'd fall into this bucket of
alcohol and they drowned and they heard
the video that's why I'm showing if they
open up these buckets touch these things
I wouldn't trust it with just little
rubber gloves I know I know so this is
just full of dead rats use those for
something for fuel yes yeah burn them to
heat your house might as well yeah why
can't they look at them it's good size
yeah decent size right like at least
feed jungle or what do animals or
something right look at a snake
[Applause]